it is time for hatred mail this week is
a very special hatred mail but first
just a reminder
what is hatred mail anyway who needs
dr fauci or the cdc
we get all the medical advice we need
from our second cousin's husband's best
friend's boss
on facebook patriot mail
written by patriots who hate david
pakman
because america and because
freedom okay so
that there is something very special
about this week's hatred mail
and it is part of something i want to
compile for you
between now and january 20th let's take
a listen and then i'll explain
david we know you're a loser and a
disgrace
but it doesn't matter and i'm not sure
how helpful publishing your videos
is david pakman has one of the most
punchable faces i've ever seen what a
condescending
in his mind loser don't worry david
you'll have four more years on
talking on trump being a loser is your
best quality
yeah i want to compile all of the people
still telling me we are going to get
another four years of trump
joe biden is not going to be sworn in on
january 20th
uh because i'm still getting these
emails and comments
and tweets and reddit posts and all of
it and
um you know at first i naively was
thinking you know when joe biden is
sworn in
these people are all going to come to a
big realization they're going to finally
realize they were wrong
no they won't they'll just say it was
rigged and biden is
an illegitimate president they're never
going to say you know what i guess we
were just wrong
we were wrong when we said when i said
trump would overturn it i was simply
wrong no they'll say
well it should have been overturned but
it was rigged and biden stole it and
blah blah
they will never concede or accept
that they were simply wrong the best way
to fight patriotism continues to be
to use the coupon code hatred 40
h-a-t-r-i-o-t-40
when you get a membership at
joinpackman.com you
save and the hatreds cry every time that
that happens